hey love and welcome thank you so much
for joining me here today my name is
Sheila and in today's video you guys I'm
going to be sharing with you 10 a clear
signs on how to tell that another way
that you can tell that a girl likes you
is if you find yourself more often than
not having to be the one to end the
conversation so if you're the one that's
like I'll talk to you later or I have to
go listen I don't know if I was supposed
to poopoo this girl she's nailed every
single one I don't know none of that I
just wanted to comment on it think about
it logic if you always engage in
conversations all right the
conversations like you know see it how
you want to see the sensories a chance
for you guys to get to know each other
if you're always the one ending getting
any other person did it that means the
other person wanted to keep going but if
you're like I got better stuff do we got
to move on you got [ __ ] to do whatever
that indicates that you are the
higher-value person and example to do
yeah and the conversation cuz I don't
want to be in the conversation anymore
yeah I'm not trying to convey status or
interest but you might have seen this in
pickup artistry books where they say
stuff flag always try to leave her on a
high note
always try to leave one at the highest
moment so that's her last impression or
whatever it might be by you leaving
first it is a bit of a Power Move it's
like this isn't that playing a game
though so here's what you have to think
about it when you are spending time with
somebody but you have to leave at a high
point in a conversation because you have
other to do that conveys to the other
person that they like you but they have
other priorities that are more important
and that they're focused and that
they're driven so it becomes an
endearing quality so it makes them
appear high-value even if they're not
playing cake now where it does kind of
seem gamey yeah is if you're
intentionally leaving even though you
got nothing else to do
just to appeal appear more higher status
which that makes it boy I don't think it
makes it boy I think we all do little
stuff like that in order to convey
attraction towards the other person okay
you know it may not be how you actually
are but it is what you do at that time
I suppose I'm dirty all the time in my
room or whatever
have a date I cleaned everything up is
that really an indication Who I am or am
i gaming I'm putting my best foot forth
which is what dating is I guess it's
companies trying to make business with
each other so he's on their best
employee sure but then the most
attractive prospect in a partner is when
they're always like that their place is
always clean they're always well-kept
yeah they're always on point they're
always busy where there's normal matches
will be sense exactly okay yeah so but
not so gamey it is there's a difference
between being Gainey and showing you I
think even for the people who are on
their best behavior all the time they
figure they're still gonna show up on a
date with better behavior I'm still
gonna wear my best clothes mmm you know
that still me putting my best foot
forward is that gave me I don't think so
it's putting your best foot forward what
makes it gave me is if you the further
you look like your representation the
more gamey it is listen dating is a game
you played you played to win dating
inherently is a game it is a back and
forth some people want to be wooed they
want to you know charmed all that stuff
you're putting on airs I'm not saying it
all has to be super phony but let's not
pretend like there isn't an element of
romance or whatever mm-hmm that's game
when someone's charming you and they're
being funny and all that stuff they may
not have read it in a manual but that's
game the flow game I salute you fine you
know what I mean a charm is game that's
just another word for it Thomas game
game is not necessarily back because
yeah that's how that's how people link
it to like Italy being gained when you
hear someone say always playing game
game game it's just like what they're
saying is that the person is not being
genuine and a person is manipulating you
into something that you're not but game
is not necessarily a bad thing I mean if
you are being deceitful to the point
where you're completely misrepresenting
who you walk to you're the person that I
could see that being a problem what do
you do how do you play the game you know
what I got to a good place I think
initially I was trying to do all these
different things but I sober six seven
years I just
now you having flatmate
no I'm pondering
I'm pondering I look at beers thing I
don't really care that much there was a
time in my life where I wanted the most
beautiful poom poom I wanted average I
wanted everything right it's like you
have it some of its overrated sounds
good you know it's like and you just
realize on my stock market it's not that
high value anymore it's not that
important I like flirting flirting is
fun it is a very fun process you know
and like the hunt yeah I think it's
normal you know it's like women enjoy
the process of being desired and men
enjoy the process of being able to woo I
think those two things are very normal
and it's not even in like a relationship
I want to teach you kind of things
sometimes I just like flirting period
yeah you know I to be charming is fun to
make people like you it's not something
I'm go out to actively do but to be able
to make people like you is a good
feeling do you think that because you do
stand-up that's where your value in the
stock market no no because you get it
here's the thing when I wasn't concerned
with the outcome the process became more
fun and because the process became more
fun the people I was involved with
enjoyed it more does that make sense
when you are going into any kind of
interaction with a lady and you're
desperately wanting to garner something
from that that comes out one way or
another so for the neatness you know
either you become a simp or whatever
maybe you're successful
okay often same thing with stand-up
there's something weird about a stand-up
comedian who goes up there and you can
just tell they need the crowds affection
the crowd turns and reels away from them
but when the community gets up on stage
they're confident themselves and even
when the crowds turning away they assert
themselves they have more odds of
winning the audience back then if they
try to reach for the audience and all
right I tell my best joke about me you
know I talk about you know that moment
when the chameleons like please yeah
please look there's something really
pathetic about it right yeah same thing
with dating mmm
so I think for me when I stopped caring
about the process is much
for me it became more enjoyable and then
I became less invested in the outcome
and now I'm just like no I tell you so
many times where I was like I couldn't
God the goods but I'd rather just say
something that I really wanted to say
and it blew everything up and I just had
a good laugh about it and that to me was
way more rewarding
I've blown up so many opportunities at
boom-boom just because you said what you
wanted to say but I sleep well what you
told me you know when we started like
back four years ago and then there was
comments yeah people the old I hate it
was real
yeah and it was a hate we were not used
to grass cuz there's a lot of people
that you don't know that just gives you
so much hate but in and we had this I
remember we had a service conversation
and I was like yo I was like yo he's my
baby hey and you was like yeah but I
don't care cuz I sleep well at night
yeah did it be real I know I sleep well
at night
he could be mad let them be mad and they
got mad can solutions to spot save me
cancel listen to inspire bro to this day
I sleep so well so yeah that tell you my
sleep was amazing and I think you know I
always tell people I know what it's like
to have regrets I know what it's like to
not stand up for whatever you believe in
or to all this other stuff so to not
have to have that negative feeling
weighing on me you know you know that
that to me is a it's like it's not you
don't feel great it's like an absence of
a negative usually block I sleep well
for someone that reads a comment bro
eight to ten hours every day really - 10
out bro I wake up feeling great sleeping
well is good wake up I love this you
know what though it's like for some
dudes getting laid is such a big thing
for them
but it is and especially if you haven't
been laid a lot or had
had any opportunities and you really
want it it's hard for me to tell you
don't chase them because when you don't
know
you don't know that you don't know but
that's a hug around it I mean that's it
that's a lot of love right there you
know I feel like a lot of men or
compensating for a lot of that didn't
have my story that was your story yeah
ugly duckling didn't get some in high
school wasn't liked and so I felt like I
was on some pom-pom real time you yeah a
real talk
I never acted badly towards women yeah I
never treated them badly but I'm life
and I never been like where's my pool I
never did that but I felt like yo I'm
old some and I'm gonna get some mmm cuz
for me to take it wouldn't be gratifying
off to me the only way it makes
gratifying is if you find me Indira so
to be able to game my way in feels great
and also the game I win with ethics so I
could sleep on it I cannot sleep well
knowing that I misled people I lied to
them about holes you know doing stuff
where I'm like I got all these cars and
whenever that wasn't me
but if I could get them being dusty
that's how great like I'm a being the
military being like clean cut and all
well dress and getting something else
cool
but when I was dusty that I was cooking
some bass game that's like that's like
play basketball five-on-five with other
pros but you got weights on your ankles
that's what feeling just like that is
like that was a Goku when I started like
putting efforts to dress like the last
two or three years and then I cut my
hair and did all that stuff oh yeah yo
we out here swimming okay Justin Trudeau
moistly what I was trying to say earlier
is like I get it for some dudes it's
such a big deal to get laid and it's
like they feeling completely inadequate
without it
so it's hard for me as someone who has
been able to get laid to tell them you
don't need that I feel like everything
out there says you need to sure all the
information that we're getting like man
needs to get if if you're not getting a
boom boom you're not successful you hear
so I get it everyone says that women say
that men say that so it's normal that
men think that they have to do that all
right kid but I also tell men once you
did it you're like yes yeah what's about
boom boom it's not about boom boom it's
that constant pursuit mmm how much you
gotta chase for the end result it's just
not necessarily worth worth it's worth
it and even when you're in the process
like it's just not a fun it's like it's
like you get these little ego boost but
you don't feel great after mmm yeah it's
like going about that but I want
[Music]
this is 2019 you guys and I feel like
more often than not 24/7 we have our
phones on us
and if not 24/7 24 8 because our phones
are gonna be somewhere around us okay
let's just keep it true so a lot of the
times we don't really try to tell that a
girl likes you every boy text and I'm
gonna go ahead and get started
[Music]
so the first sign and how to tell that a
girl likes you and this might be a
little bit obvious and it's like duh but
I have to mention it and it's going to
be that she initiates to text you first
so you're not always the one that is
rich enough to her to text her first
that she's actually reaching out to you
and that's a very very good sign that
she likes you or in the very least is
interested in you because it shows that
you are on her mind she's not no it's
not wrong no to be that when you text
her she replies immediately no but maybe
the person is just life that we play no
gentleman people like you they reply
wala faster I know I I don't know math
you know she's not wrong okay so that
means you know she is waiting for your
text she is crying in her bed and she is
waiting for her Buddha texture and I'm
just kidding jokes that she puts lol or
ha ha after text that don't really
require a lol or a ha ha I feel like
that's everybody because because we
don't have a nation in text you know we
don't have she's not wrong though like
you know I mean like yeah but when
someone's not interested in you they'll
make the text a little bit more dry as
an indication whereas by adding that
extra I'm not saying it's an indication
of the person does like you but it can
be added but it's so big it's vague it's
like yeah she's not wrong she's not
right either no she's
here's what she is because she's giving
you 10 things to look for man if it's
added to the other list of stuff then
she's right
what she immediately said well yes the
amalgamation of other stuff okay is
going to be that she puts it emojis and
gifs and her text when you sent emojis
and when you send gifs and there's what
I said emojis like that it's because I
feel like they are trying to get your
emotions across to the other person did
you yeah I don't know if it the gifts
are just the other gift as a gift I've
always had gifts but it sounds like
gifts like a gift that's kind of
confusing but it's give it's an acronym
it's the question of you know context
yo I think she would give did you get it
if it was cube X Dennis again like it's
a gift if it was again she's not wrong
like me a lot when someone is not into
you they are not going to be that
animated in text I'm not animated in
text it's not because I don't like the
person it's just because I don't like
emojis and I'm not laughing at the
moment so I'm not gonna Lala
I get I get what you're saying but I'm
saying from women when they send a lot
of gifts when they send a lot of stuff
like if they're romantically interested
there's far more likely that they're
gonna send that stuff than then they
won't dig what I'm saying the next sign
is going to be that when you don't
respond right away to her text that she
keeps on texting you and I feel like
girls do this because they're
anticipating your response and so it's
like oh my gosh
no biter he's not texting me right now
let me just keep texting him until you
text me back so yes she's nailed pretty
much all of them that's not worth yeah
if I don't respond someone keeps
responding that's an indication to me
that they're very interest of course
maybe I don't know I don't have to know
me if I take somebody I don't get a
response and my dudette to me you know
how we go about things a lot of people
don't like that if people triple or
quadruple text you odds are they're
really
is that crazy for you to think that all
my business meetings is just you know
that's a different thing
they really do like you for your money
another sign that you can tell that a
girl definitely likes you through text
is her texts are not those one worded
dry toast desert kind of texts they are
going to be actual sentences they're
going to be engaging next time so say
for example if you had mentioned in a
previous texting conversation that you
wanted to go to Six Flags together and
say she finds herself at Six Flags but
you weren't able to make it she'll send
you a picture
she'll send you a picture of herself at
Six Flags right or she'll send you a
picture of the surroundings wait do that
if they're updating you on their trips
and their stuff that they're doing in
private chats odds are they're probably
interested actually fifty pictures of
them doing stuff
I mean media no they send people
pictures you have to have a girl send me
like oh look at my on vacation and Cuba
and they send it to me privately you
know I'm just like I don't even reply
you don't I wish I could be there what
am I gonna say up like Congrats enjoy
like when I'm on vacation I don't think
about sending people other pictures but
I know people are different from you
people like to let other people in on
their vacations and their experiences I
don't give up I would be super surprised
if you'd be like oh girl which I don't
think we need to watch more of this
video because that pretty much is not
the point I encouraged her Big Ups their
output goes well for her to me this is
like duh I already know all the stuff
but I noticed people who don't know
pretty much her thing can be summed up
do they make a lot of effort in
communication what someone's not
interested in you they're gonna keep the
conversation as short as possible when
someone is interests
you know send you pictures they might
send you emojis a lot they might put lo
at the end they might do an amalgamation
of all these different things yeah
essentially this can be summed up to
someone interested they're going to put
in effort that's what this is or as
behavior that's it